a
[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález el presidente de
francia emmanuel marco ha sido blanco de
críticas y ataques por su posición ante
el islam radical la defensa del laicismo
y la libertad de expresión entre los que
argumenta está incluido también el
derecho a la blasfemia el mandatario
francés ha advertido en diferentes
intervenciones que francia defenderá sus
valores y combatirá el fanatismo en la
otra orilla hasta el presidente turco
recep tayib erdogán quien ha señalado
incluso insultado a su homólogo francés
acusándolo de no estar bien de la cabeza
el presidente erdogán ha impulsado
también una campaña en varios países
musulmanes para boicotear los productos
franceses el motivo de esta tensión
entre francia y el mundo musulmán y
particularmente con turquía es el
asesinato de samuel de patti un profesor
a quien en una clase sobre libertad de
expresión mostró a sus alumnos entre los
que había varios de ellos musulmanes una
caricatura del profeta mahoma recordemos
que para esta religión considera que
cualquier representación del profeta
oma es una blasfemia después de estos
hechos ocurridos en esa aula de clase el
profesor samuel para ti fue decapitado
por un joven checheno musulmán de 18
años el debate entonces trasciende más
allá de las históricas tensas frías y
llenas de altibajos relaciones que ha
tenido parís con ankara tiene en
francia- algún problema con el islam o
los líderes musulmanes tienen algún
problema con el secularismo no vamos a
analizar en el debate de france 24 para
conversar sobre este tema saludamos a
óscar pérez de la fuente él es profesor
de filosofía del derecho y filosofía
política de la universidad carlos
tercero de españa.el se encuentra en la
capital española precisamente en la
ciudad de madrid y también se une a esta
conversación gaspar estrada él es
politólogo de la universidad sangpo de
parís se encuentra allí en la capital
francesa los dos gracias por estar con
nosotros en este debate y antes de
comenzar el análisis me gustaría
recordarles que desde sus casas ustedes
también pueden enviarnos sus comentarios
y sus preguntas a través de nuestras
redes sociales la etiqueta es numeral
efe 24 dejen todos sus comentarios en
nuestras cuentas france24
s sant y luego comenzamos entonces
comienzo preguntándole a oscar en la
ciudad de madrid sobre estos conceptos
básicos que tal vez para la audiencia de
américa latina' resultan un poco
difíciles de entender no están muy
claros del todo y le pido que sea muy
puntual sobre este laicismo francés esta
perspectiva que tienen desde parís de
este concepto la importancia que tiene
el significado del laicismo para la
constitución del estado francés
bien pues digamos que francia se
constituye en una república laica cuyos
valores se fundamentan en una
interpretación republicana que
básicamente desde el punto de vista
religioso esto significa que el estado
no financia ninguna confesión religiosa
no puede financiar ninguna presión
religiosa excepto para la asistencia en
hospitales en prisiones por tanto que la
religión es un elemento estrictamente
del ámbito privado y esto por ejemplo ha
tenido una una representación muy típica
una polémica una controversia muy típica
que ha sido el tema del velo islámico en
la escuela pública que en el caso de
francia se considera que no está
permitido la cuestión de los símbolos
religiosos pues es muy controvertida en
los diferentes países tienen diferentes
soluciones no por ejemplo en españa se
tiene un sistema que no es el de la isla
incite de la jce y del laicismo que es
la confesionalidad
qué es un sistema de laicidad positiva
donde se tiene relaciones con las
confesiones mayoritarias y especialmente
con la iglesia católica que está regido
por un tratado internacional con las
otras confesiones se tienen acuerdos con
el estado
sergi en cambio en eeuu
pues hay una visión del establecimiento
una cláusula de no establecimiento de la
constitución que dice que ninguna
confesión tiene carácter oficial
sin embargo se tiene una visión
favorable a las minorías y a veces se
les trata diferentemente en la forma de
acomodos la zona hombres
gaspar en la ciudad de parís allí en la
capital francesa como es el día a día
entonces en francia en un país que es
tan cosmopolita que es el país que tiene
la comunidad musulmana más grande de
europa occidental tiene una muy estrecha
relación con algunos países musulmanes
sobre todo del norte de áfrica por el
pasado colonial que tienen en común que
tanto influye esto en el día a día como
es la perspectiva allí hago toda esta
aclaración y todo este contexto sobre
los conceptos básicos para entrar en el
análisis de la situación que se está
viviendo allí
bueno ahora la situación por causa de
coronavirus es un poco extraña es decir
las personas salen a las calles hay una
vida
normal aunque la vida se termina las
nueve de la noche porque hay una
imposición de pues clara del gobierno de
evitar la propagación del virus y pues
esto tiene una consecuencia en los
contactos humanos de hecho es probable
que en las próximas horas el gobierno
endurezca estas medidas sin embargo al
menos en la ciudad de parís no ha habido
una serie de reacciones contrarias al
gobierno de hecho las propias
autoridades religiosas musulmanas y
organizadas en el consejo francés del
culto musulmán han defendido las
posiciones del presidente de manuel
mccoy que cabo en las declaraciones muy
duras de las últimas horas del
presidente
erdogán ahora bien creo que en el debate
que vendrá en las próximas semanas y
meses pues está claro que en la
presencia de las religiones en el estado
francés va a volver a regresar perdón al
debate público y ese es un tema muy
delicado en francia a raíz
que ya fue mencionado anteriormente de
cómo funciona la república francesa y
como en francia pues uno tiene que
asimilarse a la república francesa para
ser aceptado en su seno y este principio
de asignación es muy claro es libertad
igualdad fraternidad y ahí en ese
espacio pues no entran las religiones
porque es una república laica ya le doy
la palabra a oscar quiero preguntarle
también a gaspar aquí no podemos olvidar
que no solamente francia francia hace
parte de la unión europea y en conjunto
con los otros 27 países pues de pronto
hay alguna unanimidad en cuanto a esta
posición cómo se maneja entonces este
tema del laicismo a nivel de la unión
europea de todo este bloque
bueno lo que hay en el plano político es
una respuesta muy clara de los 27 países
al respecto de las declaraciones del
presidente turco en las últimas horas
casi todos los jefes de estado y de
gobierno de europa de los 27 estados que
la componen han hecho tweets para
expresar su solidaridad al presidente
francés incluyendo al presidente del
consejo la presidenta de la comisión el
vicepresidente para relaciones
exteriores y el señor borrell entonces
desde el punto de vista político
institucional
la respuesta es diría yo unánime y muy
clara en respaldo al reciente emanuel
marco ahora bien en las sociedades pues
no todas las realidades son las que
existen en francia
el reino unido por ejemplo es bueno el
reino unido está saliendo de una europea
pero por ejemplo es un país como
alemania
pues no existe está esta separación tan
digamos importante como existe en
francia de separación de las iglesias y
el estado en alemania si uno trabaja en
el sector formal
uno tiene que declarar si tiene una
reducción y si es el caso no contribuye
por la vida del impuesto a financiar a
algún culto cree eso y si eso no existe
en francia entonces yo creo que a nivel
de la sociedad es algo más diferente es
algo un poco más complicado
oscar cuál es la importancia de un
estado laico para américa latina esto
resulta un poco difícil de entender y
porque en francia siempre vuelve a estar
sobre la mesa este tipo de debate cuando
es algo que aparentemente ya está muy
arraigado en la institucionalidad en la
formación del estado francés incluso
dentro de los ciudadanos
bien el estado laico se basa en dos ejes
la separación iglesia-estado y
la neutralidad entre las diferentes
confesiones esto que parecería muy
sencillo y muy simple tiene diferentes
interpretaciones según cada país y es un
tema muy complicado porque cada país lo
interpreta a su manera el el modelo
francés es un modelo de laicidad digamos
estricta y que interpreta a su modo
republicano que la religión tiene que
tener un espacio privado y que el
espacio en público no tiene que en el
espacio público no tienen que estar
representadas las religiones
por ejemplo con la ley de símbolos
sí sí sí
gaspar tomo con usted mientras
restablecemos la conexión con oscar en
la ciudad de madrid aquí hay un punto
importante después de este estos hechos
que ya explicaba yo al principio del
programa de los hechos que tuvieron
lugar en parís y que son los que han
desatado toda esta controversia entre
francia y el mundo musulmán y es que
turquía ha tomado un liderazgo digámoslo
así dentro del mundo musulmán para
atacar a francia desde el mismo
presidente turco ya lo decía yo recep
tayeb erdogán ha incluso insultado al
presidente francés porque esta posición
de turquía porque asume esta posición de
liderazgo entre los musulmanes y porque
ataca
bueno porque en este momento el logan
está en una secuencia política muy
ambiciosa y también muy riesgosa para él
y para su gobierno que es una política
de expansión política a nivel
geopolítico que en primer lugar el
partido de erdogán que ya está en el
poder desde hace ya casi dos décadas
pues ha logrado transformar el
funcionamiento del estado turco de una
república laica justamente hacia un
hacia un modelo confesional
y ahora lo que quiere es llevar esto
exportar este modelo hacia afuera lo
vemos en la presencia de turquía en
libia la prisión
la presencia turca en siria lo vemos
ahora en la crisis que se está viviendo
con armenia en azerbaiyán y es en este
contexto en el cual pues el doga no
quiere pues lleva a expandir esta
estrategia
a la unión europea que se ha
transformado en un rival geopolítico
para turquía y pienso en particular en
libia
y en siria donde francia es el principal
rival se podría decir a nivel
geopolítico de turquía entonces me
parece que lo que está por atrás de toda
esta serie de ataques verbales del
presidente erdogán a marathón hay esta
estrategia turca de expansión pero que
puede tener consecuencias diplomáticas
graves para el gobierno turco
oscar usted nos explicaba este laicismo
desde la perspectiva europea desde la
perspectiva francesa o europea
occidental pero turquía también hasta
hace algunos años era como el gran
ejemplo de democracia y de un estado
laico para el mundo musulmán como
entender entonces esa visión desde
ankara de lo de la libertad de expresión
del secularismo y del laicismo que debe
ser una mirada muy distinta a la que se
puede tener en europa
si digamos que turquía es un país que en
el tribunal europeo de derechos humanos
tiene muchos casos de libertad religiosa
y de libertad política y me gustaría
hablar de un autor italiano que se llama
giovanni sartori que escribió un libro
hace unos años que se llama la sociedad
multiétnica que fue muy polémico muy
controvertido y allí dijo que los
inmigrantes musulmanes no se pueden
integrar en europa porque no se separan
en religión de política yo no estoy de
acuerdo con esta afirmación a mí me
parece que algunos y mediantes
musulmanes vean vengan de teo gracias no
quiere decir que tengan una mentalidad
teocrática y que no puedan vivir en
sociedades abiertas y sociedades
democráticas pero sí que es verdad que
desde el punto de vista de determinadas
interpretaciones
la separación entre religión y política
yo creo que es la clave para entender la
la
el descenso entre las misiones de
francia y turquía en este momento es
decir francia parte de una separación
estrictamente religión y política sin
embargo para un el mundo musulmán esa
reparación no es tanto porque el
concepto religión es un concepto mucho
más amplio es un concepto mucho más vago
que lo abarca abarca más cosas pero es
un concepto cultural es un concepto en
cardinal o digamos
oscar y no entendiendo entonces
separando la parte política que nos está
explicando gaspar desde parís sobre los
intereses que puede tener turquía de
echarle fuego a esta a esta discusión
verbal entre parís y ankara aquí
entonces lo que estamos viendo es un
choque de conceptos de entre occidente y
medio oriente básicamente entre la
percepción que hay de turquía de lo que
puede ser la libertad de expresión y ese
estado laico que ellos conciben con la
concepción que hay en europa
a ver me gustaría matizar un poco la
expresión lo del choque de las
civilizaciones de huntington fue una
moda de los años 90 y no podemos hablar
ahora de choque de civilizaciones no me
parece adecuado sí que me parece que hay
diversas percepciones diversas opciones
conceptos de conceptos nutrición choque
civilizaciones
sí pero en el debate de las caricaturas
de mahoma se dijo que esto era se
planteado de una forma como si fuera un
enfrentamiento entre civilización y
barbarie no es algo así como que
nosotros somos los civilizados y
nosotros nos reímos de todo lo que no
queremos y en cambio está la barbarie
pero hubo otros y otras personas otros
enfoques que dijeron que eso era un
debate dentro del propio liberalismo que
era un poco la interpretación entre la
libertad y la igualdad y el respeto a
determinadas creencias el respecto a la
visión del otro o la o la libertad o sea
era un debate entre dos visiones del
liberalismo no un debate entre
civilización y barbarie
a mí me gustaría plantear el debate en
esos términos importante esa acotación
que usted hace oscar y gaspar le está
preguntando por los intereses que tiene
turquía para avivar esta confrontación
verbal entre los dos países vemos que
otros países del mundo árabe y también
países musulmanes vemos a bangladesh
hemos visto aquí
hay que acatar haciendo parte de este
boicot a los productos franceses en sus
respectivos países como entiende uno que
estos países estén adoptando estas
medidas que está promoviendo el
presidente turco y uno no ve a ningún
tipo de acción contra países como por
ejemplo china en donde hay campos donde
llevan allí a los de la minoría uigur
que son musulmanes a estos campos de
reentrenamiento uno no ve a los países
musulmanes tomando algún alguna medida o
presionando al gobierno chino por este
tipo de actividades
bueno efectivamente siempre en este tipo
de disputas lo que prima es la política
y las alianzas entre regionales entre
entre países
lo que hay creo que es el punto que me
gustaría destacar es que también no hay
que ver al estado turco como un ente
único que fuese un estado totalmente
laico porque justamente como lo dije en
la primera intervención antes de que
ankara diseñada toda esta estrategia de
expansión hacia afuera también hubo una
profunda reorganización del estado turco
adentro y hubo una pérdida de influencia
muy grande del ejército turco que era un
estado que era un ejército que defendía
la laicidad y en la llegada al poder de
el partido de erdogán primero en
alcaldía de estambul y después en
turquía supuso también un cambio y una
reducción de los espacios de la equidad
dentro del estado
en turco y ahora lo que estamos viendo
es más bien una expansión de esta
aspiración de el bogar y lo cual de
hecho le provocó que algunos aliados de
de logan pues decían abandonar el banco
porque no estaban de acuerdo con este
cambio del funcionamiento del estado
turco que era un estado laico que ahora
cada vez más es un estado confesional
óscar díaz le doy la palabra sigo con
gaspar el presidente francés a lo largo
de estos días ha dicho que tiene el
pleno compromiso de luchar contra el
islam radical esto generó todo tipo de
repercusiones y de comentarios
obviamente en el mundo musulmán macrón
tal vez se ha extralimitado desde su
punto de vista puede ser visto así con
estos términos estas palabras y este
tipo de lenguaje que ha que ha estado
dando a través de los medios de
comunicación que es también en parte lo
que ha generado este malestar allí
bueno es que lo que a ellas mejor le
está hablando a los electores franceses
después de los atentados terroristas del
2015 en enero contra harriet o después
en noviembre los atentados también que
vi que se llevaron a cabo en el año
siguiente claramente en la sociedad
francesa esté en los temas ligados al
terrorismo está buscando orden está
buscando respuestas y en este sentido
mccown está hablándole a los franceses
ahora está claro que él tiene que tener
y seguramente por eso está asesorado que
tampoco puede
por su discurso atizar justamente un
conflicto que pueda aparecer y sobre
todo darle el pretexto a otros países
para intentar generar esta está supuesta
guerra de civilizaciones y yo también el
rechazo yo rechazo esta afirmación pero
me parece que los intereses políticos
que existen pues tienden a justamente
que se usen o que se malinterpreten
estas palabras y ahí es donde me parece
que
el presidente manuel mac com tal vez ha
fallado en calibrar sus palabras porque
claramente pues él tiene dos públicos
muy distintos por un lado su opinión
pública interior en francia y por otro
lado las relaciones con estos países que
utilizan este tipo de clave
declaraciones para atizar sus
diferencias con parís yo incluso ankara
ha tildado toda la situación como una
campaña de odio contra el mundo musulmán
y oscar en estas coyunturas ya lo
estábamos diciendo este tipo de debate
sobre estos conceptos y estas
situaciones y enfrentamientos entre
musulmanes y algunos países occidentales
y toda esta confrontación verbal no es
nueva ya lo hemos visto a lo largo de
los últimos años puede que ésta sea un
punto de quiebre definitivo para para
restablecer una nueva forma de
relacionamiento entre ambas partes
teniendo en cuenta esa diferencia de
conceptos que usted nos ha explicado en
detalle a lo largo del programa
oscar
creo que no tenemos conexión con oscar
en este momento y no oye la pregunta que
le estoy haciendo vamos a revisar la
conexión y más adelante vamos a retomar
entonces la comunicación con él y el
análisis
sigo entonces con nuestro otro invitado
en la ciudad de parís gaspar y seguimos
haciendo el análisis político de la
situación que se está presentando allí a
nivel de peso político que tanto limita
esto el de baja popularidad al
presidente macro no en un país que como
todos los mandatarios están golpeados en
sus índices de popularidad por el manejo
que se le ha dado al kobe 19 a la
pandemia del cob y 19 y en un momento en
el que paris y el país entero están
viviendo la segunda ola
bueno yo creo que hay hay dos temas se
tienen que abordar el primero es el como
el gobierno francés ha tratado la crisis
del cob y claramente al principio de
esta crisis como la mayoría de los
gobiernos en europa el presidente manuel
manjón tuvo una crecimiento en su
popularidad un crecimiento que poco a
poco fue disminuyendo conforme el tiempo
fue pasando en manuel más un cambio del
primer ministro que un primer ministro
popular por otro primer ministro que
está teniendo problemas en las encuestas
sin embargo es esta caída de la
aprobación gubernamental no ha tenido un
reflejo tan claro en la popularidad
personal de manuel máximo se mantienen
niveles bastante altos para un
presidente que está abordando la el
cuarto a su cuarto año de mandato con
más o menos 35 por ciento de opiniones
positivas él sin embargo claramente
ahora con el tema del terrorismo pues
esto puede tener consecuencias muy
concretas lo vimos en 2015 lo mismo
en 2016 entonces a mí me parece que de
manera general en los atentados
terroristas provocan un crecimiento
rápido en las encuestas pero puede ser
un crecimiento de primero sobre todo si
el gobierno de manuel makoun decide
implantar un segundo confinamiento
generalizado en las próximas horas
entonces yo creo que hay que que el
escenario puede cambiar en los próximos
días y semanas en función de las
decisiones que tome el gobierno de
manuel más kaspar ya vamos a analizar
las relaciones entre país entre parís en
ankara y el resto de los países del
golfo que están en este en este plano
general de lo que está sucediendo en
este momento con esta situación retoma
entonces la comunicación con óscar y le
estaba preguntando oscar allí en madrid
en la capital española sí este momento
en el que estamos no será un punto de
coyuntura para mejorar ese tipo de
relaciones que hay entre francia y los
países musulmanes aprovechando esta
coyuntura porque no es un debate que ya
que sea nuevo esto ya lo hemos visto
varias veces este tipo de debates
el laicismo la importancia del estado
laico en europa cada tanto viene a
quedar otra vez sobre la mesa porque
este sea un punto de quiebre y haya un
cambio en la en la mirada
e
sí
bueno puede ser un punto un punto
interesante digamos que una de las cosas
que se plantea es hay un derecho a
blasfemar
digamos que se puede decir que
y el adiós lo que hay es delitos de
ofensa del resentimiento los religiosos
digamos que puede haber un derecho a
blasfemar pero algunos dicen que no hay
un derecho a ofender y por ejemplo la
regulación española lo que hay es que
se puede expresar libremente sobre
cuestiones religiosas o hacer bromas
religiosas siempre que cuando no haya
una intención de ofender
los jueces siempre encuentran otra
intención como la hace reír la de
criticar la de informar que no es la de
la de la de ofender y por lo tanto no
condenan por el delito de escarnio que
es el delito de ofensa de los
sentimientos religiosos quería plantear
una reflexión que es la siguiente una de
las caricaturas de mahoma era un
musulmán con turbante
el turbante era una bomba
algunos dijeron que se podía hacer este
chiste y que estaba era divertido hacer
este chiste y otras voces señalaron que
eso esa forma de de target y no de
señalar aún un grupo de seres humanos
los musulmanes como terroristas era una
forma del lenguaje del odio y que por
eso porque era un tratamiento de las
minorías para desprestigiarlas para
denigrar las quizá alguna restricción a
los límites del humor se tenía que
establecer lo dejó como un interrogante
es lo que se está debatiendo un poco
pero sería sólo en casos extremos y sólo
sería en casos donde hubiera
implicaciones del lenguaje del odio no
en casos donde hubiera
[Música]
humor y humor aunque en este momento en
el que estamos con esta coyuntura de
pronto el momento indicado para llevar
ese debate a la mesa
sí por supuesto yo creo que las
relaciones entre los países tienen que
ser así tienen que ser interesantes
antes se ha dicho por ejemplo del modelo
asimilacionista ya sé que es una gran
tradición pero por ejemplo a mí los
modelos el modelo diferencial ista
alemán el modelo asimilacionista francés
o el modelo multicultural anglosajón me
parece que han entrado en crisis y que
habría que haber otro modelo de
deformación de las relaciones
interculturales
se tendría que ver si a mí lo que me
parece es que el debate del velo
islámico y el debate de las caricaturas
de mahoma son son debates superficiales
y lo que está de fondo es la integración
de los inmigrantes y de los ciudadanos
musulmanes en los países occidentales
y sobre las condiciones de vida de estas
personas no se habla
importante es acotación ya le doy la
palabra a gaspard hago otra pequeña
pregunta a buscar uno de países de
europa donde la integración de
emigrantes musulmanes es aparentemente
exitosa casos por ejemplo como el de
suecia en donde hay una gran cantidad de
iraquíes iraníes kurdos que han llegado
a este país y han logrado tener una
integración un poco más fácil y se han
integrado la sociedad sueca tal vez
francia está fallando en su modelo de
integración
o sería el momento de replantearse otro
modelo de integración
es decir yo lo que planteo es que el
modelo republicano laicista lo conocemos
es ampliamente algunos consideran que su
modelo ideal pero digamos que
actualmente en europa hay personas que
tienen una religión y la religión es el
centro de su vida y la religión les da
una fuente de valor muy importante
entonces eso
hay que gestionarlo de alguna manera
hay que saberlo gestionar de alguna
manera entonces a lo mejor el modelo
tradicional laicista tiene que
modificarse o tiene que acomodar a estos
maestras personas de alguna forma que no
sea manteniendo sus creencias en el
ámbito estrictamente privado sino que
puedan tengan digamos estas personas no
tienen ese modelo de que las creencias
religiosas son estrictamente privadas y
entonces eso es un poco lo que está en
conflicto claro sí para el cierre ya me
quedan pocos minutos para terminar el
programa le hago dos preguntas para que
usted responde a puntualmente estas
relaciones que tiene
parís con turquía y con el mundo
musulmán qué tal se han desarrollado en
los últimos años y cómo ve usted el
siguiente capítulo
que va a pasar de aquí en adelante como
ven ustedes jugando un poco aquí a la
especulación y a la bola de cristal cómo
va a desarrollarse esta discrepancia con
ankara cómo va a terminar este boicot
contra los productos franceses
bueno yo creo que ahorita en ankara
turquía tiene está en una posición creo
que delicada porque ha multiplicado los
frentes en los cuales efectivamente
hasta ahora ha tenido cierto éxito
piensa en particular en los casos de
libia de siria pero al multiplicar estos
frentes pues también multiplica sus
enemigos y
en este caso creo que está muy claro que
la unión europeo va a dar una respuesta
firme a turquía lo cual no no ha sido el
caso hasta entonces en particular en el
tema migratorio y creo que paris va a
tener más respaldo de sus padres
europeos de lo que era el caso hasta
hasta hace poco tiempo para atrás pero
que también habrá que observar con
atención lo que pase la próxima semana
en eeuu y sobre todo si hay una
alternancia porque no está claro que el
gobierno de joe biden
apoyo al menos pues no le dé atención a
lo que está pasando en el medio oriente
entonces yo porque ese es el otro punto
que hay que evaluar y yo creo que en
este momento quien está arriesgando más
estancada más en parís
oscar para el cierre la conclusión que
cree usted que va a pasar de aquí en
adelante lo que se viene para las
próximas semanas en torno a esta
coyuntura
yo creo que la situación de la unión
europea con turquía es un poco
ambivalente porque la unión europea
tiene un acuerdo con turquía sobre el
tema de los refugiados
y digamos que que le paga dinero por
tener refugiados y está cuestión de unas
declaraciones del presidente macro y
sobre todo las declaraciones del
presidente turco también parece que las
declaraciones del presidente turco no
son políticamente correctas están fuera
de la corrección política porque alude a
una enfermedad mental
o lo que hay es un problema cultural de
entender la separación entre la iglesia
y el estado para entender el secularismo
hay dos formas de entender el
secularismo entonces esto no tiene nada
que ver con pruebas mentales sino que
tiene que ver con en todo caso
diferentes interpretaciones culturales
pero para eso son servidores públicos y
para eso son políticos para ponerse de
acuerdo en cómo gestionar mejor los
asuntos públicos claro
óscar pérez de la fuente y gaspar de
estrada muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros aquí en el debate de france
24 muchas gracias a ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]